[Applause]
one question an amazing lineup of CEOs
Founders and experts this is marketing
for the now can you hear
me thank you so much that made me
feel
[Music]
ofad
welcome everybody happy world kindness
day it's a special Monday for all of us
really fired up to have a conversation
today we're going to be focusing on how
to unlock the growth mindset we've got a
a tremendous crew here um we're going to
be kicking things off with the CMO of
the
WNBA um Phil cook and I think Gary's
going to be joining us in just one
second I can feel it I can feel it oh
there there he is hi hi hi hi I was just
mentioning to everybody it's World
kindness day happy world kindness day
happy world kindness day happy Monday
all right we're gonna jump right on in
talking about unlocking a growth mindset
and guess who we have first who Phil
cook the CMO of the WNBA we were just
talking that he uh has been at the WNBA
for a while where he's driving fan
growth and brand and strategic
Partnerships but 27 years at Nike before
that
incredible I'm Gonna Leave it to you too
to kick it off thank you how are you
it's great to see you brother it's been
a how are you man good man first of all
congrats you know I know we uh we had a
one-on-one meeting not too long ago and
it's just been so exciting to see the
momentum of the league and the brand and
I think for everybody who's watching
here and definitely the hundreds of
thousands of business and marketing and
pop culture leaders that listen to the
podcast over the next several weeks and
months I think we can all agree that
from a net net gut feel Common Sense
standpoint uh there's been a lot of good
going on in the WNBA and that makes me
really happy for you and them yeah you
and me both Gary I I I think you know
you hit the nail on the head when you
said momentum it is H certainly in our
favor right now we you know another
successful you know Season under our
belt and and growth everywhere which
we're very excited about with lots of
potential still on
top um so talk to me about this you know
you know I think that one thing that
really took me back and I really enjoyed
our meeting over a year ago whatever it
was now I sense the growth mindset you
know I think a lot of times CMOS talk
growth but they're actually on defense
um and I you know what do you for
everybody who's listening what does it
require um politically in a corporate
environment mentally for yourself work
life balance with a family strategy how
do you keep up on it like there's so
many places you can take this fill I'm
curious where you will take it how do
you define unlocking a growth mindset
you know we're we're fortunate that we
have such a great platform from which
you know to pull growth from right we
have 144 of the greatest athletes in the
world and their influence stretches
beyond the court it
stretches uh certainly into culture and
into purpose and when you have that
canvas from where you can you know you
can craft stories and you give your team
the ability to
unlock those stories and find new and
creative ways to you know Inspire and
engage fans it's you know the limits are
are endless and and that's what we've
done we've really started to again lead
with our athlete stories make compelling
content a lot of it learn from that keep
creating and you know it's it's typical
flywheel it it's working and and the
engagement and our partners are finding
the same formula and when they do it
it's it's
Unstoppable what do you think the
opportunities of Distributing your
stories are for growth mindset marketers
like where do we need to be like at the
end of the day it's all storytelling
yeah where do people fall in love with
their Stars you know obviously that
landscape changes every decade every
half century
what's you know for the growth mindset
individuals out here who are operating
organizations whether they're an
entrepreneur with five employees trying
to sell flowers or whether they're a big
organization what's your hot take on the
growth mindset um what the storytelling
platforms that really can capture the
execution and actually create growth you
know we're we're getting sharper at who
we want to uh share our stories with
right we've always had a very loyal fan
base and we can keep engaging them and
and that's that's kind of the foundation
for you know the W at age 27 I think the
opportunity in front of us is to find
those fans of of sport and of
competition and of culture and find new
areas from which to share our our our
stories uh and new platforms and and
look we want to get younger we want to
get more diverse we want to do what so
many other brands do obviously
and we know
that we know that that women's
basketball let's just use that as a
SharePoint can can certainly reach
beyond the confines of fans of women's
basketball and I'll give you an example
last year was Final Four right the
stories leading up to the final four
championship last year incredible and
Their audience went from five million to
10 million and those that five you know
what's funny Phil you know what's funny
about that those two stars it did feel a
little bit like magic bird 100% right
like that's our reference point right
like that that 1980 I guess is what it
is yeah um final four which then
dovetailed into them going into the NBA
and long before Michael Jordan came
along there's I mean the 1982 NBA Finals
was not live in America it was on tape
you know insane that is CBS chose to
show golf instead of the NBA fin in
1982 that's where the NBA was and then
so you need these people that transcend
and create growth and obviously those
two did last year and you've got the
same thing happening in the in the Pro
game your game um I there it's
unbelievably exciting in general women's
sports I think is more virally a combo
with you know soccer proper football and
with what's going on in WNBA final
thoughts on the watch outs there's a lot
of CMOS and CEOs listening especially
over the next month or two as this fully
gets consumed not just
live what's the cliche corporate bull
crap that stops
growth ah your willingness to accept
risk you know I I think I think to truly
unlock growth you've got to be willing
to fail and and I know that is a little
cliche but it it it's true like like you
don't know what's really going to make
that that incremental
until you try some things and you've got
to be willing to some of those things
don't hit and we're we're getting to a
point now where that's part of our
offense get out there fail fast and and
go and I again it is a little cliche I'm
trying not to be but we we have to be
confident in the fact that it's okay to
take some big swings because if you
don't take big swings when you have
momentum it's too late when when you're
falling off the ledge right so this for
the people that are naive to corporate
is it just like people get fired and
they don't want to lose their big jobs
like is that what like the big I mean
you're a senior exec is that like what
you sense about you and your
contemporaries or the way you grew up
the people that hold your spot now that
you looked up to and wanted to be one
day is it really as simple as that like
you take a big swing it's a PR Miss and
you become the casualty and like that is
the fear that stops people from doing
smart contemporary
stuff I think all of that I honestly
don't think it it leads to firing I
think it leads to a personal like I
just I just took one but you get over it
and you learn from it and and and I
think that's what I'm trying to
encourage my team to do take the risk
it's okay if it doesn't fail you won't
get fired if it doesn't work yeah I
think right it's rare it's rare thank
you so much brother congrats on
everything in WNBA we're proud of see
you Gary love
you thanks Phil Gary we're gonna bring
up Casey O'Reilly next she's the CMO at
Stuart
whitesman and she's she's a courageous
one she's has three months under her
belt at Stuart Whitman and I love that
she's driving brand heat in addition to
eCommerce and all everything else that
has and she's in the in the busy period
for H for uh the holidays uh but she
came from Proctor and Gamble and had a
19-year career there at sk2 in Olay and
lived all over the world so we'll hand
it her over to
you hello hey Case how are you good good
good to see you Gary great to see you
congrats on the gig and we'll get into
it in one second but I just want to give
a shout out to everybody watching Victor
Ramirez on LinkedIn Jonathan pce uh good
to see you on LinkedIn as well Martin
Katz on YouTube like the brand heat
comment uh super simple marketing good
to see you as well uh really really
really uh appreciate everybody who's on
we're seeing your comments please keep
adding to it case obviously you're
you're in this new role an iconic brand
especially with known for an iconic item
the boot has all its strengths and
weaknesses that come along with it you
have this incredible run I'm going to
give you some flowers when audre said 19
years I'm like did Casey start when she
was seven two days to
you that that PNG skincare routine
clearly worked um um you know obviously
a long run in in an iconic institution
like
PNG here's a good question unlocking
growth mindset when you're the new kid
this is something you can really help a
lot of people because a lot of people
are going through transition how do you
how do you walk lightly because you
probably don't want to come in too hot
yeah but I'm sure you have your own
passion point of views especially with
fresh eyes of like man we're not doing
this and that talk to me about that yeah
no I I was thinking about that this
whole unlocking growth mindset for
myself like how did I go through that
how did I grow within that that path and
really I'm a parent of two kids um
middle school and grade five and you
just really hear them do a lot of self
negative talk in their heads like I
don't know this or I'm not good at this
and as a parent I really wanted to learn
how to help them and I know it's out
there but really this power of I don't
know yet that word of yet is something
like really really powerful and I the
more that I exercise it with my kids the
more I also accept I actually can do
that as well in my work like I am the
new kid um and you've been all in those
meetings also everybody seems to be like
smarter than you and like all higher up
but and you're almost scared of saying
that um when somebody asks you and you
don't know you're scared of saying I
don't know but actually it is
okay what matters especially especially
in those first 100 days exactly there's
ever a time to be like I don't know I
don't know why I don't know that first
six months is a huge opportunity and to
your point a lot of people blow it out
of being insecure and not deploying
humility as a weapon exactly or saying
already something that you know as if
you know the answers to to to to us
there but same and nothing turns off a
team that's been in the trenches for a
while than someone who's coming out of
left field and acting as if they already
know everything exactly so it's okay to
say I don't know but what you say next
which is that yet and also what you do
afterward is what matters the most and
what will set you apart when you follow
through and actually go back you know I
said I didn't know but I went out there
and figured it out and this is what
we're going to try so the things that
you do afterwards is what's going to
like um you know make you think that
it's okay to say I don't know so that's
uh this period is really all about that
that that acceleration of learning
listening um but at the same time a
little bit more biased towards action
it's super important that in this first
like 90 days you put stuff out there so
that you quickly get to that flywheel of
learning of that that that failure that
you guys were talking about them just
now but yeah that's how it's been it's
been really exciting and fun do you
believe that you can unlock growth more
in the honeymoon
phase or or you because again this is so
great to have you on a show because so
you know the nature of our industry
people do end up in a lot of different
places so lot and this time of year so
I'm excited knowing a lot of people
listen to this over the holidays and
getting into January and may impact them
do you believe that when you get a big
gig top of the food chain in marketing
or anything else for that matter that
you're better off attacking the growth
in the honeymoon phase of the first six
months to a year or do you think the
strategy is to tread lightly and try to
do the action in year two that's a
really fun question DeMar where you're
going to go yeah no I I mentioned it a
little bit earlier but really as a
leader I think um there is that
imperative to have a bias for Action um
that's probably what U impedes a lot of
growth when there's so much um analysis
and um you know talking versus like
starting to create put stuff out there
so that you could just really learn
faster and just never stop incrementally
improving things so that's I guess what
I would say that the um doing something
now would be better than doing something
like a year
later what um let's talk about growth
mindset in you know obviously going
through the Proctor machine a lot of
marketing Talent a lot of legendary
Talent there when you got there as a kid
which Mentor most showed you what growth
really looked like and maybe let's get
you know I think people don't give
enough flowers so let's make someone's
day here hopefully someone will forward
them this video which Mentor call if you
feel comfortable call them out by name
and tell us the story where you said
okay I don't need to be robotic about
this this is not Academia she or he did
this I learned any any story pop to mind
when I go there case yeah probably know
know who he is like sandep is my mentor
he's a current CMO from coach and I
really remember one project and actually
specific one day that we were working on
something together which was actually
something that is a first in the world
like this smart store in Tokyo like
something that um combined AI facial
recognition all of the analysis that you
could do for your skin and it was doing
things that have not been done before
and the day before we were supposed to
open nothing
worked and I was the lead for that
project and I was like dying I was like
I can't
I can't like just fathom how to how to
figure this out and the entire team was
really so so sad and down and um we were
ultimately of course afraid like what
will our boss say like s was the the big
boss then but amongst everyone he was
the most positive at that moment that
mattered you you really felt that he got
your back and that it is okay that we
could figure this out it's the next day
it's not about this is the biggest thing
ever but hey we're opening a learning
lab you guys help figure this out some
things are working what's your input
like so it kind of like switched a
little bit in in that sense so there are
ways out there are always like Solutions
and knowing that your boss your or or
the people above you has your back and
that you could do it you know that's the
biggest unlock for everyone um in the
team the the the number one thing that
is required of leadership is the elimin
of fear yeah absolutely absolutely I
know you guys were talking earlier about
this said about being fired but it's not
it's not that like we really do care
about what other people think about us
like would I be seen as a failure or
would I be seen like I'm not in in my
aame but you just have to like um
believe that uh everyone just wanting to
do a good job you know and that your
role is that to help support them and
Empower them to to grow into that
goodness that they have
in the last minute that we have I'm sure
you thought about things we might touch
on or you wanted to talk about anything
we didn't touch on that you'd like to
bring to the
conversation
H I know I would say I would just really
go back to that um thing about as a
manager as a leader now it's important
to have your teams back it's important
to to um you know role model that
Curiosity even at this level okay to say
you don't know learn it with the team
and uh you know it's it's it's it's
really wonderful to think about always
having that yet as a word out of
allity Casey we're ruin for you I know
we're in the same
building hopefully see you in the
elevator stop by it's always great to
see you good luck good luck thank you
thanks Casey all right Gary we got
another good one coming up we've got our
friend daa who's coming in live from
Portland the CMO
van she too is it's kind of early on in
your tenure there is that right tra yeah
got another Nike vet uh we were we were
just having a little reunion in The
Green Room beforehand it sounded like uh
there was like a little bit of an
overlap with Phil almost 20 years and
she also uh did her fair share of globe
trotting and was at Timberland as well
so can't wait to hear a little bit more
about how you unlock your growth
mindset hey tra how are you
hi Gary first and foremost um most
important thing I need to say to you
happy birthday for tomorrow Gary yes
thank you very much tomorrow the big 48
oh yeah okay so what are you going to do
not much I'm actually very weird you
know people find this very funny I'm
very weird about my birthday I'm so out
there and I I don't think people realize
this about me but like this is going to
make people laugh I don't like being the
center of attention when I don't think I
did anything that merits being the
center of
attention and so this very weird
relationship with my birthday because
I'm like you know it's almost like I
usually I really just want to spend time
with my parents because I feel like it
was their moment you know like in some
weird way so anyway very small family
stuff looking forward to it I Drake I
don't want to take up too much time on
my birthday especially because I'm a big
fan of yours in the conversations we've
had over the last three years I actually
genuinely believe you know when we had
had this I was like I really hope we can
get her on the show for this one I think
you ooze growth mindset you know we
haven't had the luxury of really working
together under the hood but our
conversations uh during coid and as
we've gotten to know each other I really
think it's in you I I think the word
choices you use the way you talk about
it so you know it's as big of a co-sign
as give you're on this incredible brand
now I mean Vans is like I'm sure
everyone in the comments like get me
some Vans I love Vans it's such an
iconic brand um you know I think Vans
went from being a Cali thing it's got so
much juice now in urban culture I'm
actually curious myself when you think
about growing or the growth mindset for
Vans now like where can it go what do
you have to look for because it's almost
like we're on the third bite of the
apple with Vans right it was very Surfer
skateboarder dude now it's like crossed
over into pop Urban culture like cool
kids in the hood Rock Vans not just
Jordans I'm actually curious where do
you go next yeah well I think a great
question I think a couple of things one
is to go back on the because I'm I'm as
you I'm obsessed with uh the growth
question uh and I think especially for
people in our industry it all starts
with the belief right that brand
elevation is leading to Brand growth is
leading to revenue growth and you really
need to believe in that and I truly
truly believe in that and then at the
center of the brand elevation process um
because there's a recipe right um is
knowing who you are one knowing who your
consumers are but also when in that
Dynamic knowing where you are and how
you need to evolve to make sure that
you're also part of the mindset of the
future
generation um and it's it's really that
tension with um are you making the best
decisions for what your brand stands for
therefore you need to know what it is in
relationship to the consumer do you know
everything about the consumer and the
culture that surrounds the consumer in
relationship to the marketplace that
they are or you are dealing with and
that can be Global local it can be a
neighborhood right and I think that's
really the the recipe for us as
marketeers but also as Business Leaders
to to secure the future of your brand
and the relevancy but also um the
targets uh the financial targets that
come with it what's the what what do you
think what are the cliche roadblocks
from actually going on I mean listen
growth mindset means offense versus
defense you know so you know from your
perspective and knowing a little bit
about your career you get into a big big
company like a Nike some of the brands
you're working on now have more Nimble
budgets and realities you know the
preciousness of the swoosh is almost
impossible to touch right it gets very
hard what do you think of the roadblocks
you know again this program is so
consumed by the majority Fortune 500
marketers and things of that nature what
is a watch out now that you've been
through the game or or even more
interestingly give me a cliche watch out
and how to navigate through
it I think watch out for all of us it
doesn't matter if your brand is big or
your brand is small it doesn't matter
matter the watch out and I see it all
the time I see it all the time is
disconnecting from your
consumers uh is a big watch
out stopping when people stop to have
the
obsession uh to know everything about
their consumers and it's that
combination of Art and Science
especially in this times of where we are
right data are incredibly important but
you need to have the insights that come
with intuition intuition is based on
experience experience is based on
repetition to contextualize this data
and then again over and over again it
doesn't matter if you're big and small
when Brands evolve globally iconic
locally adopted personally Lov Brands
and they have to they can never forget
where they come from so it's really that
tension as well that is quintessential
and if you if you look to Vance right
first of all as you said we are the
leading skateboarding brand we're
anchored in skateboarding it's our
tagline of the wall right now how do you
then
dimensionalize your authenticity and
that vision of who you are towards
different kind of audiences and there I
say the audiences that are creating the
future not only the ones that took you
all the way to where you are
today who was the first person you came
across in your career that really showed
you like oh it's possible to do offense
work and actually be consumer what
you're saying is and which is I my
probably why I align so much with you I
I just think that almost everyone is
boardroom Centric and not actual
consumer Centric we sit these fancy
meetings talking that none of
our customers care about and it's
challenging because you want to uphold
brand but the problem is you need so
much creative that's relevant to so many
different consumer bases that people
that want to uphold brand academically
get stuck because they think like they
are so literal literal around brand
interpretation so if you if you stand
for
optimism however they see optimism they
want to see it every video and picture
but like for me I think losing is an
optimistic framework I think being able
to
lose makes me optimistic about you but I
could imagine me showing a video to
somebody who says our brand start stands
for optimism and I show you a little
league baseball game and a 9-year-old
loses and strikes out and starts crying
that you're going to see something
you're going to be like what the hell
are you talking about Gary and I'm going
to say no you don't understand this is
the moment this nine-year-old became
strong and resilient which is the
ultimate
optimism that's
challenging how do we get around
relevance in the face of people being
literal in a boardroom and not consumer
Centric oh my god um that's for on your
birthday for a couple of bottles of wine
I can go
this again the word Common Sense the
word common sense right um I I see it
over and over you look at data right and
you're not able to contextualize data
there's a difference between the what
and the how in order to have the how to
contextualize you need to have
experience in the field work and you
truly truly need to be passionate about
your consumers be and about your brand
because if you connect those to in front
of the opportunity you're going to
create new space you're going to create
um things that don't exist yet right and
new space we believe and I'm sure it
come because we come from that school
and uh again one name I definitely want
to drop in in my career there's a couple
of them Trevor Edwards for sure um uh
you
know taught us and again it's Nike
culture as well but also today someone
Sandy bodagger they were as much in the
field and they were looking at data and
it's really that combination that allows
you then to say let's go to new spaces
when you create new space you will
create future Revenue growth by then
pulling it into the company and make and
scale it right and we all wholeheartedly
uh coming from the school we believe in
that and we still believe in that today
um there's a lot of things that have
changed since thousands and thousands of
years of humanity there's things that
haven't changed right the fact that you
need to create new opportunities because
that's also what Innovative thinking is
about to then say how are we going to
capitalize on it and build a new uh
products of the future concepts of the
future right um and I and I truly truly
believe in that as a grow driver and as
a brand innovator it's great to see see
you again have the best week bye thank
you Tia the comments were going wild
Gary I see it I'm reading them out here
thank you so much good rest of the show
all right happy birthday a little early
I wantan to give Jill a big kiss big hug
the background all right gotta run see
you all right see you all right we're
gonna bring up Mima Johnson M where are
you hello hello oh my goodness oh you
got the you got the deep voice going on
oh I totally planned that I like it I
like it so Mya is a group creative
director one of my faves and she is
going to lead a conversation one with
one of our dear friends Jill Crest who
is the chief marketing and experience
officer at H&R Block she's leading tons
of transformation and she's come from
some great Brands including PayPal
National Geographic MasterCard and more
I'll leave it to you two
ladies amazing thank you so much Andrea
and Hello Jill thanks for joining us hi
MAA great to be here thanks for having
me of course and thanks for uh thanks
for joining us um I know we have such a
short amount of time but I actually
wanted to jump off of one of the things
that um Andrea was sharing in her intro
of you so as everybody heard you have an
incredibly impressive background and you
could have really had your choice of
roles so would love to hear why how you
chose H&R Block to help you grow in your
career and what you want to accomplish
yeah I love brands that are doing big
jobs for consumers and the H&R Block
which has historically been a tax
preparation company is really at the um
the has a front a front row seat into
what is happening with middle income
Americans today through the lens of
their tax return and I just thought it
was a really fascinating opportunity to
be a part of the next chapter of what's
happening at H&R Block the tax moment
for most Americans is the most
significant financial moment of their
year
75% well you know good or bad right 75%
of Americans actually get a refund and
so just that job that we do for
consumers to ensure that it is um you
know it is done right it is done
effectively that they get every credit
they get every deduction so that was
really interesting I love brands that do
real jobs for real consumers and then
the other thing that I loved about it
was to continue to grow as a marketer to
really bring together my experience
which has largely been working in the
digital space and driving consumer
growth and connecting that in the
opportunity that we have at H&R Block to
bring what we do digitally into what
happens physically through our 10,000
retail locations so really honing kind
of how do you do Omni Channel marketing
and bring together online and off CL
data through the lens not only of
marketing but of creating really great
seamless connected experiences and it's
a brand in transformation which I love
oh I love oh my gosh there's so much mey
stuff so much there yes I feel like the
L luckiest marketer out there to have
this job for sure and I think it's so
interesting like you said there's so few
opportunities where you get to work on
something where literally everyone in
America has to participate right like
nobody can get out of doing their taxes
so that's such a cool opportunity as a
marketer
yes um one thing I wanted to dig on and
we're even seeing a little bit of this
in the comments so uh I I love the hype
that we're getting but um being a fe
female CMO and we've seen some pretty
incredible ones on the show here today
is unfortunately a pretty small Club
even still um and it's even more rare
especially in the financial services
space so a huge kudos to you for making
your mark there but we'd love to hear
what other advice or what advice you
have for other women who are trying to
get to the top of their fields
especially if they're in ones that are
also very
male-dominated yeah I feel I'm really
fortunate to have grown up in such
supportive corporate environments
whether it was at you know MasterCard
National Geographic PayPal now very much
at HR Block I think the thing that has
been really core to my growth has been
investing in
relationships and really building
connections across the companies that I
worked in and I I spent 20 plus years at
MasterCard I really grew not only as an
executive there but as a person and as I
look back on that so much of what
fostered that growth was investing in
peer relationships investing in
relationships um with Executives and
really through the organization so up
across down and really pushing the
boundaries of my curiosity and ensuring
that I was always learning and so that
meant building relationships for example
at a global company with people in you
know regions outside of the US so I
could understand you know how I could
apply something that was happening in a
growth market like Brazil for example to
what was happening in the US and that
Curiosity meets relationship really I
think has been one of the the core
elements of how I was able to to bring
growth to how I thought about my role
and to the company because I had a lot
of those connections and so I think
there's an incredible return on
relationship and I think is women were
really well sorted to to do that and to
just get out there authentically um be
curious learn and really don't
underestimate the importance of
relationships and not with those that
you just work with every day really
doing that extensively so that you're
learning and you have context that
allows you to participate more
effectively and bring a real point of
view into
meetings oh I love I love oh my God I
wish we had like a whole hour just to
chat about this I guess that's my
question to your point of like the
Curiosity that you've brought the things
that you are trying to cultivate through
your relationships and grow that way
what what's next for you I feel like
you've accomplished so much um you know
what would you say are the things that
you really want to grow in next as you
look towards the Transformations that
you are working towards at H&R Block
gosh there's so much that's happening
both in what we're doing in marketing
our brand and continuing to build on the
incredible trust that we have and that
important job that we do for consumers
but to disrupt ourselves to continue to
find ways to be very customer Centric um
I love the work we're doing with you
guys at Boehner to really unlock the
opportunity of audience growth um we're
really excited about that this year
particularly given how
challenging it is financially for
Americans you know really understanding
what is not only on the hearts but on
the minds of our audiences whether we're
trying to win with
uh you know students who are just
entering the workforce um you know
single moms who are just struggling to
get by so really unlock unlocking the
power of audience is something that I'm
really excited about and the other thing
is as a leader I'm really focused on how
I lead my team I'm fortunate to work
with some incredible marketers I've got
a really great team and I think for my
next period of of growth as a leader
it's really being there to support them
and to really challenge how I've showed
up um how I empower how I challenge and
how I work across my organization to
really encourage them to unlock growth
and and work more closely together so
I'm really focused on my legacy of
leadership at at this period as well my
God I love that I know we only have a
few more minutes left so we're gonna
wrap it up really quickly but would love
if you have any parting words or final
advice coming off of our previous
question for other women who are just
starting to grow in their career is
there anything that you wish somebody
would have told
um Junior Jill if you will when in
marketing um that would be helpful
listening here uh today absolutely I
think if I could go back and talk to
Young Jill one of the things that I was
so clear on when I started was what I
had to do I was very ambitious I'm an
oldest child I wanted to win I still
love to win the thing that I learned
throughout my career was that it's not
only about what you contribute it's
about how you do that and so I think for
me as a leader it was was really
unlocking that not only curiosity about
business and about uh culture and and
how we could win but curiosity about
myself how was I being perceived how was
I being seen as a leader and I think for
all of us that combination of not only
the wins that you're getting on the
board as far as what you're delivering
but how Are you delivering it and those
who know me well know that you know I
move fast and one of my continual areas
of improvement is to slow down to speed
up and just checking in with myself and
being vulnerable like learning about
what you're not doing well to inform how
you can be a better leader that's a
really I love that I think that's great
parting words of learning as much from
what's not working or what you're not
doing well as as what you get praised
for is one of the things that I feel
like it takes so long to learn and I
wish somebody would have just told me
from the beginning so it matters what in
the how oh my God amazing Jill you have
been phenomenal as you have been
throughout your whole career and what
you're transforming at AG our block so
thank you so much for your time today I
really appreciate it the comments are
blowing up um everybody wants to hear
more from you so we'll have to do a part
too but Andrea I'll turn it back over to
you you guys got nice and personal it it
it means a lot and you're right people
people want to hear it they want they
want the clues about how they can get
ahead right but in the right way love
loved all of it love you both thanks for
joining us bye thank you all right next
up we have Nick
meas he's the chief client officer at V
going how we
doing I'm inspired I'm inspired today
Goosebumps on these last few aw it's
been good right we got a great lineup
and the next one I can't wait for this
conversation this is big this is big I
mean it it is it's Crayola it's funny
because when I was on the on Jim stingle
podcast he asked me what was the first
brand that I fell in love with and who I
mean Crayola it's just so
iconic um and Nick I don't know if you
looked at the list of responsibilities
that Vicki has and I don't want to take
up too much time because it's a very
long list but let's see she's uh she is
in charge of all things marketing
activation digital strategy and she
focuses on consumer Communications
social digital Omni Channel interactive
app portfolio education marketing and
Crayola Studios I'm kind of curious
about that one uh but I'm going to let
you guys lead the conversation because I
know this is going to be a special
one gr mindset and an Ever growing list
of responsibilities it sounds like
Victoria thank you so much for joining
us this is a real treat um one of my
favorite most loved brands have the
memories encoded hardwired into my brain
from when I was five so um let's have
some fun it's a quick 10 minutes so
we'll do a little bit of lightning round
but for everybody shake it off a little
bit we're in the middle of these
interviews leave in the comments right
now what is your favorite Crayola Color
let's go no question Wisteria I know
some people are going to have to look it
up but is a like a liil like shade of
purple all right Wisteria for everybody
out there put it in the comments now
we're gonna look at this afterwards
we're gonna compare the data on this um
all right growth mindset Crayola is one
of the most iconic Brands ever um you've
been doing a long time how do you think
about staying relevant stacking the
growth on top of the decades and
generations you know it's a big first
question but uh what do you think yeah
well first of all a big task right first
of all don't screw it up second of all
how do you find a way to actually leave
it better than you found it um actually
this year Crayola turned 120 years old
it's our birthday year and um when it
was originally
found o do we have a connection issue to
K potential so as we kind of looked at
how Crayola has evolved over those 120
years the key for us has been find and
be really really clear about what's
sacred and then don't mess that up
whatever you do don't mess that up and
as you can imagine a lot of those things
have to do with the with the brand but
then also be clear on what's flexible
and that a lot of it has to do with the
business model and there's a way to find
a combination where you fearlessly
protect the
brand while you continue to drive and
evolve the business model in a way that
120 years later Crayola is still as
vibrant um as successful it's continuing
to grow and you know just very recently
a completely independent study has um
rated it as number three most culturally
resonant brand Beyond um only Amazon and
Google so a lot to be proud off um and
to continue to push to get that growth
oh my goodness all right so there are
certain things we hold sacred then
there's evolution of business model talk
to us about Innovation you know like the
color proliferation new markets new
business units you know how do you all
think about Innovation new news for
driving growth for you know a brand that
when we close our eyes we can see it we
can smell it you know um sure inov sure
well first of all Innovation as for any
business really critical it's Paramount
but I think what's been really key for
us is not to think about as product
Innovation um it is absolutely true that
Crayola has amazing designers scientists
marketeers who who Envision and design
this amazing Innovation but what's
really been kind of breakthrough for us
as a company is to add to that and think
about our business model as that that
includes products experiences and
content and when you think about
Innovation across all of those levers
and the amount of opportunity
Partnerships things that it's opened up
for the brand has been incredible so I
say Innovation absolutely but I think we
found a way to think about Innovation
that has really unlocked tremendous
growth for us and what's the process
like I think that's where our audience
might really love to go a little deeper
is like is it somebody has a thought on
a Saturday it's like I think we should
go do this is it we put ideas and
Concepts into focus groups like how do
you get there how's the sausage made
high level without giving away all the
Trade
Secrets Victoria can you hear us okay
yes I froze there for a little bit but
it looks like I'm back hopefully I am I
think you're back yeah we can hear you
did you hear the question or
no we'll give it a
second yeah I can hear you you can can
you hear me yeah cool so um I'll just
I'll re I'll restate um what's the
process like around Innovation is it you
all sit around in ideate together you go
out into the world to learn more about
what the consumer wants um you know
without giving away the trade secret how
does it how does it work yeah look I
think it's all the above you know it's
it's not going to be surprising for me
to say that great ideas and Innovation
can come from anywhere but I think to me
the key thing is really sometimes S as
marketers we tend to get caught up in
thinking about what we want to say or
what we want to bring in the marketplace
but if you think about it from a
consumer point of view what is it that
they need to hear what is the true need
or an opportunity or what that can we do
to be truly helpful I think that can
sometimes unlock a very different way of
thinking about whether it's
communication whether it's actual
Innovation uh something more concrete
but really opening that up and taking it
from a consumer point of view
um and then putting your brand lens as a
second
layer super cool um let's switch gears a
little bit knowing you know time is
short um on the culture side of things
you know what happens in the four walls
how do you as a leader and the other
leaders of the company Inspire the
growth mindset you know if you come to
Crayola is it you know a know known that
we are here to grow you know we are you
know um that type of an organization
yeah is that like hardcoded into the DNA
well couple of thoughts first when you
said the growth mindset I mean I think
the the operative word is mindset and
I'll give you an example if you go to
histo to Crayola historical archives and
you put in some operating plans from
1980s what you will read is language and
I
almost literally quote that says Crayola
is an evergreen brand with limited
growth potential so when you think about
it that way what do you think you're
going to get right and now fast forward
40 years and nothing could be further
from the truth so this word mindset and
reframing your perspective I think is
just so powerful because you know how as
that expression goes you reap what you
saw right and um and I think it is a lot
about your perspective your mindset how
you think about your brand how do you
think about your business what business
you think you're actually are in um
really identifying the orthodoxies that
you might have and really flushing that
out and figuring out how they might
getting in the way and frankly sometimes
getting out of your office and and I
don't necessarily mean literally some of
us are in offices more than others but
literally talking to people who aren't
living always and breathing and are
always in the same conversations that
are sort of tangential to your business
that give you a different perspective
and maybe flip how you think about
certain things on its head I think if
you put those dots and connect those
dots and put those things together you
can often come up with some really fresh
new ways of thinking about how you can
reframe and change your perspective and
can open up a lot of opportunities and
you know and you asked about culture I
would say is that is so important
because you know culture in the business
is a lot like a river right it's used to
flowing a particular way um and kind of
being able to reroute it sometimes is
not that easy but you have to be
prepared for a lot of change management
and I think you have to have a
combination of a leader or or some
leaders who really lay out the vision to
lay out the path that is not always a
consensus based exercise but the
implementation is absolutely that takes
a village and the entire organization
needs to be involved to get there so
being able to balance those I think is
where you can unlock some really
powerful growth and help reframe how you
think about your business oh my goodness
I mean let's end on that that's a high
note I love the analogy of the river you
know
can't really s very true though right
but um so so thankful for you joining
the show um what's let's close with this
what's big looking ahead now that you're
120 what's gonna happen the next hundred
years what's your forecast with Crayola
hey we're gonna continue to lean in
we're gonna continue to to look at
amazing products
collaborations experiences whether it's
interactive retail uh lbe is a really
you know fantastically growing part of
our business
and you mentioned um before Crayola
Studios um you know Crayola announced
our new Venture into entertainment and
bringing our mission and our purpose to
life in in entertainment and connecting
with kids and families in that way as
well so going to be a lot of more
exciting things coming from
Crayola awesome I'll leave you with one
idea on the growth mindset yeah more
paper table cloths so I have a
one-year-old and she already loves to
draw on the table I mean it's a use case
like just get rid of the cloth
tablecloth and business is going to Boom
so jul not it it's going to to that to
the Innovation team today right get it
there beautiful thank you thank you
thank you truly appreciate it thanks for
having me bye all right I'm joining team
W area it's official oh wow I didn't
know thing team is where it's at we are
the strong
blue I love it the questions in the chat
were pretty phenomenal including all
right how many people have actually ate
a cray when they were a little kid
little kid what about
adult a
staple good appetizer that was
fascinating I love that one Nick thanks
for joining us all right cool we see
youat all right see you soon all right
next up we have one of my dear friends
Sarah Rodell who is the CEO and founder
of loop andai she's dialing in from
Austin Texas how's it how's it going
Sarah Sarah oh I'm so happy to be here
what a good day to get to spend together
I know it is and the funny thing is
Sarah and I have been celebrating World
kindness day for a couple years now it
feels it feels like even more than a
couple years but um really excited to
have you on the show today to talk a
little bit more about what you're doing
at Loop and Thai and how the growth
mindset how you you know sort of have
lived that across you've you founded lop
and Thai 12 years ago so would love to
hear as an entrepreneur your whole
perspective on the growth mindset but
first I want you to tell people a little
bit about what Loop and Thai is sure so
Loop and Thai is a giftgiving platform
and our mission and vision behind what
we're building is to turn any corporate
gifting whether it's gifting to clients
employees um all those people in your
commercial sphere um turn all that spend
into a social impact engine uh so the
way we do that is through letting our
customers send choices of gifts so their
recipients get to pick out what they
want and all of the options are really
thoughtfully curated and have beautiful
stories behind them so you know it's
it's interesting so full disclosure uh
Vayner has been working with Loop and
Thai for two years now and it's really
transformed the way that we look at
gifting for a number of reasons I think
we fell into the bucket that maybe a lot
of businesses did where for some reason
we just don't act like humans when we're
looking at gifting um in the in the
corporate world and so you helped us to
not only deliver a platform that makes
it super easy um but you kind of changed
our whole perspective on how we build
relationships and how we can think about
making connections in a way that does
have some social impact but also I don't
know just allows us to get closer to
people in ways that's that are I think
much more interesting and sustainable
too would love love your perspective on
you know kind of the the big nature of
trying to change um a current that's as
as you know deep-seated as that one in
terms of corporate gifting and and you
know what that why you even decided to
do that 12 years ago well first good on
you guys for modeling that growth
mindset and being being willing to
explore and shift and change um because
that's kind of the name of the game um
but I I love talking about corporate
gifting um in the sense of understanding
um it as sort of this metaphor of a
larger space of formality that often
exists within any sort of client you
know employee relationship where we sort
of have this way of doing it that's
always been a certain way it's sort of
the thought accounts mentality um and
that is becoming less and less relevant
um it's not just the thought that counts
anymore people are looking for something
that is more substantial than that and
gifting to me is this really I call it
an acupuncture point in the system where
if you hit this one point it just sort
of filters out and touches all these
other things um and and I think that
because it's really the quality of uh
how you connect in these particular
moments that can influence the tenor of
the rest of your relationships and if
you're giving someone something only
when you want something that's gonna
have a flavor right versus if you're
doing it just because it feels good just
because a part of your brand your growth
mindset your nature is to celebrate s um
that comes through and those are the
kinds of experiences and those are the
kinds of actions that end up building
lifelong brand fans and lifelong
relationships yeah you know it's
interesting because Gary has always been
a big subscriber to looking at yeah how
are you showing up um and and and doing
that through surprise and Delight or you
know just showing that you care about
people at different times not just
because it's the holidays which is
typically when especially in corporate
gifting you see that everybody sends
their gifts you know in in the December
time frame the same way and you know
yeah the same way and so you know we've
been able to I love the platform because
you make it so easy to be able to send
things out around the world um but to
allow people to pick the gift that they
want and they can give to a philanthropy
or they can pick a fair trade you know
collection or whatever it might be but
we really love the idea of celebrating
something that's not celebrated world
world kindness day um and to your point
this year you helped us in taking it to
a different level where we took to the
streets around the world and just talked
to people about kindness didn't even
mentioned that they were going to get a
gift and then we gave them a you know we
gave them a loop and tie um link so that
they can go and pick their own gift and
it was so shocking to so many people and
it it um and they're now gifting they're
paying it forward as well which is a
cycle what happens you know and I have
to tell you I don't know if I've ever
told you this but um the thank you
economy was one of those seeds of just
at the beginning when I was thinking
about starting the company just having
that concept of how we are starting to
expect different things from businesses
and what that's going to mean for how we
connect was one of those you know years
ago um light bulb moments that I was
like oh my gosh yeah and gifting is a
part of that and the way that we
approach gifting and how we can move
into this onetoone space while still
honoring the scale requirements and you
know the the ways that um we're you know
of course interacting with more networks
than ever um but we're not we don't have
the patience to be treated in a way that
feels um like a formality which I'm glad
for good job humans yeah good job humans
yeah for something I don't want to be
treated like another Cog in the wheel
absolutely not so tell us more about
your story that you know as an
entrepreneur you know standing up a
business from scratch and looking at the
various chapters of growth how have you
been able to you know kind of graduate
from from one stage of your company into
you know the next and continue to grow
you know there's so many themes there
and I'm such a different person than I
was at the beginning and I think one of
the biggest things that I've given
myself Grace on is at the beginning I
was trying to copy everyone else in the
sense of like oh you know I was 25 I was
like what do you what do you what what
does being in business look like right
like like trying to just um you know
everything I read I was like okay this
person knows better than I know and and
really kind of giving away
my own um point of view I think a little
bit too easily and over the course of
the time that I've been developing this
business and you know of course as we
develop anything we're also developing
ourselves right um really kind of
leaning into that space of trust um
around what may feel good for me or what
may feel good for Loop and TI that might
be totally different than anything I've
seen any company do um than anything
I've seen any other leader do and having
that okay um and that's taken you know
for me that's been a lot of exploration
a lot of burnout on you know it's really
exhausting to try and take a model that
works for someone else and retrofit it
for yourself and I think it takes a lot
of time doing that to be like you know
what this this isn't working for me you
know what do what do I need and what
does this business need and also you
know every that every time you move move
a chess piece the board changes a little
bit right and so understanding the
dynamic that we're working in
um you know we've gone through so many
different massive macro changes um and
cultural changes over that period of
time and so I think not having a growth
mindset um for me and and being more in
that reactive space was just not going
to work and so the way I internalize
okay what does it mean to be in a growth
mindset um it's really just every day
being curious about what worked for me
the day before that might not work today
what works for someone else that I can
learn from but might not work for me and
really kind of individualizing and
personalizing the experience of
information and then coming up with the
version that works for you you know I
love that uh yeah it's almost like
learning how to treat yourself like a
human as well and one thing I'll say
about you Sarah is that you're so
generous with everyone around you that
you collect good people and that the
exchange you get from that is you know
is is pretty incredible you're always
helping to give me ideas and then I can
tell other people want to give you ideas
too just because you are that that
person that human that leader um and so
you know it's it's kind of ironic that
we do this on world kindness day but but
you are one of the kindness kindest uh
Business Leaders I know and it's nice to
see how that can be you know it can
create momentum for others as
well speaking of momentum it sounds like
uh you have a little something to share
with our audience yes um so on this
world's kindness day um we want to
empower as many people as possible to do
random acts of kindness for others uh so
we have a web page at our URL which is
loopen tha.com
kindness where you can nominate someone
that you want to send a gift to um to
celebrate them and um it doesn't have to
be for any reason at all just because
you love them and so we're gonna go
through those and send out as many gifts
as we can fantastic well that's that's
so wonderful thank you so much for
joining and for giving us all that gift
just yes yes well thank you for having
me and thanks for recognizing this day
it's so fun oh thank you Sarah we will
see you very soon all right bye all
right thanks everybody for joining this
show uh we are going to have one more
celebration of marketing for the now to
close out the year and that's going to
be on December 5th at noon so please
come back bring your friends and uh have
a great world kindness day thanks for
joining us bye-
bye